foreign
[Music]
who kind of looks like a hobbit uh that
one and a company that totally knows
what it's doing you guys no reason to
panic comes a thoughtful series about
the power of dreams but just the
Cinematic linear kind not the ones where
you have to mow the lawn with your naked
dad
the Sandman
enter the world of Humanity's dreams
where the dreamlord keeps our fantasies
on track like a super goth Kevin feige
protocols which must
but when this berries and cream boy gets
trapped inside a glass cage of emotion
he'll have to escape and put our worlds
back in order with the power of roofies
and this relatable fantasy where the
real nightmare is having to catch up on
work while you're out of the office uh
Gods I can't deal with this mess right
now do you know how many dream males I
have in my inbox Tom Sturridge shines as
dream as in he's so pale it reflects
light he plays this God like a combo of
Roberts from Smith to Pattinson with a
kind of sad Boy energy unseen since the
Golden Age of Tumblr it is natural to
die as it is to be born we do not choose
to be created I feel like
nothing
chill as this porcelain doll face sets
off on three epic quests that form the
season the quest to retrieve his
precious stuff my sand my Helm my Ruby
the quest to stop a black person from
taking his job
and the quest to become somewhat less of
a dick you're not going anywhere
enough
please no
evolving from the kind of guy who'd kill
your pet in episode 2 to one who'd
merely threatened to steal your child in
episode nine it is mine and one day I
will come for it what you can't really
blame him though he literally comes from
a family of D bags desire delirium
Destiny death Despair and the others
meet a world range of characters with
near infinite power where the only limit
is imagination and the effects budget
like Rose Walker who must choose to
embrace or reject her Destiny as a human
McGuffin what's a dream Vortex you are
her groupo who's so warm and accepting
they have shockingly few questions when
one of them gets raw dogged by a ghost
we're taking good care of her Road
Matthew who is either Patton Oswald not
bothering to change his voice at all at
your service Rose or Patton Oswald
admitting he naturally sounds like a
talking bird but I don't get a sense
that you're listening so
[ __ ] let's go to hell lucianne a
librarian who doesn't have to use energy
to shush people
Gwendolyn crispy who steals the show in
a life or death game of I know you are
but what am I I am
die I'm
I am a hunter I am a Nova
well I am a Nova times infinity
who proves if you want a skinny twerp to
be hiding ultimate Powers you call David
thulis and the Corinthian an American
Nightmare whose peepers are no worse
than Steve Buscemi's but his presence
really highlights how English our
Collective unconscious is Chesterton do
you eat I have tea I have tea and
biscuits should be amusing if nothing
else oh I can't believe it I even gonna
say imaginary world eh absolute Legends
Naf so while the tech companies race to
throw their money at expensive genre
projects and HBO takes their content out
for a nice drive
all right
Netflix is hanging in their baby with a
faithful 160 million dollar adaptation
of one of the greatest Comics ever and
it's actually pretty good see this is
what happens when creators own their own
characters you know DC would have given
it to David air and Jared Leto in 2008.
starring Morris Lee Walker Vortex Ranger
a chew to a Kill Patton Oswald Alfred
Inferno Wild Wings hocus poet God this
is Halloween Spirit Halloween I want you
to haunt me The Exorcist a literal Field
of Dreams
and your average adult Disney fan
little Emos adventures in Slumberland
this is actually the ideal male
friendship a dude you catch up with at a
bar once every 100 years did you know
the Andor series is honestly Kick-Ass so
far if you're ready to accept Star Wars
into your heart again let Kim knapsog
take you on a deep dive into the history
and evolution of the Rebellion click the
thumbnail on the right to watch now
happy birthday Francesca
bad words in Spanish I'll do you one
better why is epic voice over guy camp
on Awana we hold you in our hearts and
when we think about you it makes me
wanna fart